so we did this first he pushes
remember he's just pushing
the eyes pushing on you do you see that
remember and you felt the two uh
resistance the first one was the brace
right here as you braced
and the second one was when you felt
your balance go whoa
that's where your ego tripartite kicks
in so you have dichotomous
experience of the rule he's trying to
get
me and then your will to power kicks in
life will be a lot better if i get him
that's still dichotomous okay but
instead as he's going in i'm just
letting that hand go live no
contestation on his hand
so if you pay attention when he goes you
go like this
and that's what's taking it off
so i go inside this hand i let him push
do you see let i want him to push if i
stay here
that's my contestation if i move with
his push
you see
so i'm inside this one i let him push
i move in and i project on the shoulder
so don't contest this one you're going
to lose this one
go inside this one let him push you on
that side and
go around the push he goes
and you disappear
okay you guys see that so don't contest
the first hand
don't try to control the first hand go
inside
it and then use the second hand don't
try to contest the second
okay try it so this is not a momentum
throw
where i'm going like this i'm ahead of
him and i get out of the way and
then my trained monkey he does a forward
i'm not doing it and how do you know
that because he
he puts his head here and that's where
the roll goes
do you see
he puts it he goes right into the roll
a projection throw he doesn't go he
wants he wants to go there
but he's gonna go over there okay
he goes pull and pop
okay now find the x pattern
you you find it shout it out where is it
the first arm leads the head in the way
it was originally going
the chest hand arm is going to project
over the hip
across i'm going to say not quite
your right hand is going to project his
where's the left arm going
around all right where's the
shoulder hand going crossing across
okay so this arm is going like this your
foot
this arm's going like this
he goes take the foot and this hand is
going like that
so this has gone here it starts to bring
it around
then this shoulder arm goes this way
so i combine the two
across
two okay try it again